talk about getting locked up I know the
last time you you you you were down when
you got out you had a battery in your
back yeah that was kind of what kind of
like was was that was that motivation to
really get on this campaign for sure
take us back to that that that mentality
when you when you went to jail last time
and you was sitting in your cell
thinking about like damn I can't take
what I got for granted because I
remember talking to you and you were
like [ __ ] knew who you were in
jail and [ __ ] you know what I'm saying I
for sure they're getting on me too like
the homies the homies beat and be
devastated when I slide through usually
you know it's a celebratory situation
right one of the Army's coming gang but
you ain't here for one you like wait
yeah I'm saying undercover Lee hoping
the [ __ ] got a little time so he can
come big everything right kick what they
be disturbed when I slide in they're
like yeah I'm saying what is your doing
and and I'm talking about the ones that
genuinely loves me anybody else they
happy to see me but the ones who
genuinely love me to want to watch me
struggle and I'm standing and watch this
marathon take place you know they um
they feel some type of way man and I
appreciate that
and that go a long way so when I be in
there I just it'd be like bright [ __ ]
you better get it together
don't double back here and they can you
double back here [ __ ] it's up and you
know I be in their planet plotting
strategizing writing down what I'm gonna
do and I'm gonna do it how long it's
gonna take me to do it and I'm standing
and when they crack the gates but I'm
sitting in there I'm sitting there and
I'm impatient I want to do it now
anything that I can do right now over
this phone I'm calling home and I'm
trying to get it there breath we got to
do this breath breath we got it you know
I you know it's ugly for me right now
but soon as I get out I'm telling you
bro I need to hold this and we got to do
this hit dude until dude this looks like
a machine and moving in are you trying
to keep it afloat and you impatient and
you can't wait cuz you could taste it
and then they crack them gates me yeah
you get the child L you get to bite down
you get to prove it so when I came home
I already know I was fake wait gang
was like like gang chief yeah I'm saying
and that's how that's how the gang test
was teach treating me so uh you know the
suckers was on my line like you know I'm
here on show we gotta clean him up and I
was I was you know I was they knocked I
got shot at a lot
whatever the case but even going through
CPS fighting CPS fighting probation I'm
saying getting into it with the homies
cuz no I'm shooting up so it's just like
all odds against you it's like it's
crazy and I was still able to Juke move
and hurdle jump over them hurdles and
them obstacles and and and still
overcome all all the negatives and
everything that was against me Manning
and firing and find my niche and so uh
it's just crazy it's crazy hella
thankful beyond blessed and I'm grateful
a lot of gratitude so I try to give back
in any shape and form